hey welcome back Isaac you know we've
got um we've got the beginnings of a
fantastic smash hit triple-a rated
computer game here yes we've done some
good bit some tossing out what we're
doing and we've got a screen now what
what do we do next yeah so so far we
just caught as you said the screen we
got the wall strong and we know how to
do that with pie gain and actually I
ended up the video explaining how to
make the program to wait for something
to happen otherwise you know pie gang
will just simply quit and just throw and
quit and that's not what we want so
that's why this while loop is here just
waiting for events to happen so what
we're going to be doing in this video is
to focus on implementing that ball
moving around how we do the trick to do
that so I want you to get back to my
definition in my first video in which i
was planing what the ball object will be
right so this is the class boom a class
this is the way that we have to define
in Python or anything any other
programming language how the object will
behave right so what I'm going to do my
code is split into three main parts for
now so the very most here the scenario
down here and what I want to do in the
middle is to define my classes right so
I'm going to define a class for the boat
and we're going to call it bold nothing
fancy right and initially you can just
say this class is going to be doing
nothing and then later on we will have
to implement the paddle as well that
initially it does nothing right so what
do we need in the bowl so if we look
again back on the paper we know that for
the ball we want to store coordinate X
and y we need that road so that's going
to be lets say intrinsic variables of
that particular class so for that to
happen on Python which is slightly
different from other programming
languages you need to define a
constructor here in it and then you do
need to provide the input for X and one
so whenever we create a new ball we need
to tell it where to put those
coordinates right so Bay
you need to create the ball and then
give it values just like this so the
position of X is going to be the X that
is being given and the position of Y is
going to be the Y that is actually given
by the user so now that I have defined
this I could simply create a bow object
and to create a bow
basically I could do it down here before
we through the scenario so create
objects so we're going to create an
object right that is called bow the one
we're gonna be using to play which is
gonna be of this type of object which is
bow and the two arguments as you can see
already when I put this is telling me
that the arguments are x and y so where
do we want to locate the bow in the very
first place so for that what you need to
do is to get back to your drawing and
think okay I want the ball to be in this
particular position on the screen so
initially initially you just want to put
the ball close to the side of the screen
right so it's gonna be the x position is
will be with minus the radius of that
bone right because we're gonna be
drawing up from that point in there so
that could be the width minus the ball
radius huh but we haven't defined that
yet actually we do need to define it
here in our world class so you need to
define here and then we can give it a
value for example 10 that will remain
the same for every ball object that we
create we're gonna create just one in
this particular game by the way but
that's how it works so you could do this
and then you say Bulldog radius so
that's the x coordinate and the y we
just want to sit the ball in the middle
of the screen so we have that variable
height and then I wanna just in the very
middle so we divide that by 2 and I'm
using two of them just to get the
integer out of these two actually right
so as you can see shown is really really
important that we define those global
variables that will be very important in
our game because if we define it
manually then we're gonna carry all
those numbers all the time it's gonna be
very tricky to get it right
and then one small modification will be
a mess in the whole code so that's why
we reuse that so here we can create that
now if I run that nothing is gonna
happen at all we're gonna create again
the window here I didn't throw anything
at all right
so that's the first thing I need to do I
want to show the ball so to show the
ball you in Python you always have to
include the object self to do stuff in
there
and then you need to draw a circle there
is a truck just outside that already
just moving all around you know this is
a nice state and they're working outside
and we cannot control that here the
second function that we wanted to
include in our ball was something to
make it appear on the screen right so we
actually need to draw the circle so
pygame will provide actually a function
for that that is also within the class
draw instead of a rectangle we need to
basically draw circle once again if you
look at the documentation you will see
that you need to provide where in the
surface which surface we're using
because actually you could create
multiple windows if you if you want to
and so you need to use the screen now
this is a bit funny because this screen
is a global variable it's something that
we're using here down here so you need
to tell python look I'm gonna be using
that global screen that's a bit of a
tricky thing to do with python by the
way and the next thing that you need to
to say is the color once again that as
you may remember that was PI game dot
color and then you need to say white
right if you want it to to draw it white
actually it could be nice to have this a
bit in a different variable actually and
be able to draw the ball in different
colors so what you could do is to
basically use an argument is a parameter
here color that whenever you want to
show the ball you indicate that color
and then you use the object from PI game
and right after that you need to say the
coordinates x and y of the ball which is
basically the position of that
particular ball so that's why we use
self
the ex self dot why to indicate where
the position of that particular ball is
and then right after that you need to
indicate the radius and with that pygame
should be able to draw that circle on
there right so this is what we do so we
have defined the class we can create one
and now we need to actually show it
where do you want to show it we could
just simply show it right after this so
whenever you do you've done the wall so
you could do both play dog show and that
will work hopefully let's see that
actually so when I run the program I
actually did something wrong why look
it's complaining down here saying
missing one positional positional
argument decoder because I forgot to
mention that I want this to be the
foreground polar which is this pi game
color wine yeah so I forgot to do that
so that's why it's complaining and it
doesn't do anything then so if I run it
now that should be here there we go
beautiful home it's very small one
actually I think I maybe want something
bigger than that so let's modify that
let's put 20 maybe right so we can throw
the ball but okay that took us again
quite a bit of time so how do we
actually make it move well presumably
you have to draw it somewhere else right
exactly but we want the ball to move
automatically that's actually kind of a
weird thing to think of it's not like we
want to be telling the ball to draw we
won't just able to move all along
through x and y-coordinates so that's
why I I was saying before in the
previous videos that well this is my
first definition of the ball class
language I just said x and y but
actually the ball will be alive so
actually that ball will be moving
through x and y so actually we should
include here the speed and the velocity
on the x axis and the one on the y axis
so that will be how much we increment
the position and move the position of x
and y every single step right every
single step of the game so we're gonna
have to add this to
to our class definition so we are gonna
have to include VX and V Y and I'm gonna
completely to yourself DX and going a
bit quick in here but that's how it
works so whenever I create the ball now
I put before only two parameters but now
we have two more which is the speed that
we want this to go let's say on the
horizontal axis and the vertical one so
initially for example I'm gonna say that
I just want the ball to move
horizontally not vertically so the one
on the y axis is gonna be zero and for
this one I can say for example let's say
minus one I just want one pixel to move
every single time but I want this to go
from the right to the left of the screen
and expose a positive number right so we
want this to go one by one
actually I don't like this as you know I
don't like to type and hard code
anything I'm gonna create a variable
which is called velocity
I'm gonna define that in my global
variables here so velocity will be equal
to one and we're gonna have minus one to
begin with right so this would we have
but now we still need to make it move so
to make it move I'm gonna create a
different function that will be updating
the position of the ball and that's
gonna be happening automatically what I
want to do is to show the ball in the
next position right so you just want to
update the position of x and y based on
the velocity so basically what I'm
saying is the position X will be the
position X plus that velocity right so
we're going to increment that you can
implement this nicer if you want to but
for now let's do nice and dirty code and
there you go say self dot one plus the
speed the velocity on here whenever we
have increased we have modified the
coordinates what we can do is to use the
function that we implemented before to
draw it again self dot show we need to
put the color here so that means that
this function will also me
a parameter cooler as well all right so
that's how it works and is that is that
it we will see I'm gonna I'm gonna just
go ahead with it you know that's not how
I like doing programming shown is you do
something you try you see that it's
failed and then you refine and refactor
your code right so that's a good
practice actually just to play a bit
with it so we're gonna update and what I
want to do is to update that
automatically so we're in the code we
should be doing that we should be doing
that within this while loop so the while
loop is just waiting for things to
happen right so unless the user click
the cross well we can actually just
simply call both dog update based on
that foreground color and that should
actually draw the ball in the next
position something I don't want to
forget right now is that whenever I draw
something on the screen is not ball it's
both play so we update the surface but
we need to flip it right you remember
that I told you you need to flip every
chain that we do in the surface so this
line up here shouldn't be here it should
be within the while loop because we want
to draw it in a different position and
update the surface and draw it in a
different position and update the
surface so basically I'm gonna cut from
here and put it right after this right
so well I mean I think actually you
should do it the other way around so we
do it this way okay if I do this what do
you think it's gonna happen soon I'm
worried that you said when things go
wrong so I feel like something's not
gonna be quite right but I'd like to see
I don't know something is gonna go wrong
very wrong this weird updated but you
will see this one is pretty funny oh
dear
hey it's going I mean it works but why
did we get that line well because we're
just drawing the ball over and over and
over again right yes but we didn't
somehow eliminate the previous ball
right so the trick the trick to make a
bow to make an object move on the screen
PI game is to draw it again so in the
current position you put it black you
put it with the background color and
then you paint it in the next
pixal right in the next step what we're
going to be doing is to use this
foreground and you should use also a
background color that is gonna be pygame
color black so we're gonna use that as
global variable and what you should do
in this update I made it before
with this parameter but maybe it's not
even needed what you want to do is to
use those two variables background color
and foreground color as global values
from the our program and the first thing
that you do is to hide the ball you
actually hinted it before shown so first
thing you do is to put it in the
background color before you update
anything at all and then you update and
then you use a foreground color in the
new position so that should now work
I hope let's see if that works Oh
something is wrong yes because update
doesn't have a color so that's a mistake
that I forgot - I have Chiang Abed the
definition of my function update and I
forgot that I don't have to indicate the
color because I'm using global variables
for this alright so that should work now
oh there you go Shh oh man can you see
that we seem to draw a hole in the wall
what why do you think we got the hole
well we didn't tell it there was a wall
there we just can't told it to keep
moving to the left and drawing black and
white like am i right actually the ball
is now being drawn somewhere outside of
my screen it's getting negative numbers
and trying to draw it outside then it
cannot right so the next step would be
to manage the collision of that ball
with the wall right and so how do we do
that so basically this is actually not
too difficult
we basically need to think of what are
the coordinates of the wall and tell the
ball hey whenever you're gonna collide
do not draw it do not collide just
invert your direction change your
direction so if the velocity was
negative now we want a positive we want
to change and go to the other axis so
just to manage the collision I'm gonna
leave that as an exercise for
if you want to continue doing the game
basically what you need to do is to
modify this update function and before
you actually update the position x and y
you need to check and for example
restore that new position on a different
variable and check am i already touching
the border and that means the wall here
but also the top and the bottom walls
you need to check those two and change
the velocity so now have precooked days
for you how to update the position of
the ball to manage the collision with
the walls right so this what I'm doing
here and down here and now if we run the
code and actually I'm gonna do something
funny I'm gonna change the velocity also
for the wine axis so you see the ball
doing something nice so if I run this
you will see that this goes and touch
and return and then the ball will go
away and we'll never get back right so
this is what we managed to do in a
series of three videos I think so far
and and basically show you already all
all you need to complete the game on
your own now you need to define the
class for the pub and then you need to
for the problem as I said is the Y
access what we want to control I'm gonna
show you that in one minute but then the
rest of the game is for you to decide if
you if you want if you want to see more
just let us know and we will make more
videos detailing how to do that part so
I'm gonna copy pace a bit again precook
code just to show you that the game is
actually doable but no more than that
I'm guessing the paddle is is gonna be
you know a thing that you move but also
the ball you just need to then check
whether the paddle is there or not you
know and it acts a bit like a wall if
the puddles there right yes exactly yes
so do manage then you need to manage
collation but then you can manage that
within the ball so the ball will not be
updated the position and then you need
to control what the paddle is so but the
panel class that's the one that we are
dealing with at the moment so that
public class is the saying ideas before
but now we're drawing a rectangle and we
only use the position why because we're
going to remain the X in the space that
we want we are going to be using a
function from PI game that takes word
fishing of my mouth yes so the idea is
for you to try to complete that on your
own but if you want to see a more
detailed video on this I'm happy to do
that but otherwise I'm gonna show you
the final gain this what I have in here
and I'm gonna run it and now you can see
the boat moving all around it goes a bit
actually a bit fast right and that's
because typically you do need to do
something you need to control the speed
of the program depending on your
operating system this while loop that we
have down here we have to control it and
to do so you should be looking at the
documentation and looking at something
called clock that will make this while
loop to behave in the way that we
actually want right so this while loop
in here has now aligned clock that tells
me they update the frame rate in which
the ball will be throwing from pixel to
pixel right otherwise it will go too
fast or too slow I think on Windows
actually goes amazingly fast on Linux
code okay on on Mac goes like very slow
like a turtle super slow alright so this
is the final game but it's not still
final so if you want to know more we
want to do data science now on the game
to improve it and knowing that we are
going to be able to predict the position
of the paddle for new positions down
here so if we get the position of the
ball and the speed I want to know where
I normally put the paddle to go